주변의 분들도 좀 보셨을 텐데
주변의 얘기를 거의 안 했어요
왜요?
주변에서는 제가 보수인 줄 알아요
아주 친한 거래처 사장님이 계신데
유튜버를 한 명 추천을 해줬어요
그분이 추천하는 것만 사요 이제
혹시 돈을 내야 되나요?
돈은 안 내도 되는데
쿠팡도 뭘 누르라고 그러고
빨간색은 다 팔고
물린 거는 다 저렇게 두는 게
물린 종목이 안 좋은 건 아니지
꽃은 뽑고 잡초에 물을 주는
그렇죠
아니 그렇죠
거꾸로 얘기한 거야
제가 신용으로 많이 샀잖아요
변호사가 주식을 신용으로 사요?
아무도 안 그러셨어요
제가 한 번도 안 해봤어요
왜 안 하지?
그러게
저는 예전에는 진짜
천 원 이상 주식은 잘 안 했거든요
천 원 이상 주식?
그러니까 천 원 넘으면
이거 너무 비싸니까
유튜버가 알려주면 어떡할 거예요?
그 선생님은 그런 분 아닙니다
그런 분 아닙니다
그 선생님은
그 선생님은 욕하지 마세요
개미는 지금
두 분 잘 지내셨죠?
어서 오십시오
우리 슈카님 친구분
우리 이호재 변호사님
그리고 이땡땡 회계사님
어서 오십시오
사실 저희 거에 나오고
조회수가 또 상당히
잘 나왔어요
주변의 분들도 좀 보셨을 텐데
반응이 좀 어떠셨는지?
저는 주변에 얘기를 거의 안 했어요
가족들한테도 아무한테도 안 했고
저희 와이프만 알고
친구들한테는 딱 한 명한테만
왜요?
주변에서는 제가 고수인 줄 알아요
걸었을 때만 얘기를 많이 했기 때문에
실은 저번에도
이땡땡 회계사님하고
저희 방송 출연 하루 전인가 봤잖아요
저희가 실은 걱정을 좀 많이 했어요
우리가 이게 남들은 이렇게
사회적 지위가 최근에 있는데
나름 사짠데
걱정을 많이 했어요
솔직하게 드러내도 되냐
회계사님이 자기는 가려야 된다
제가 그렇게까지 하냐라고 하면서
그때 처음 저도 회계사님의
적나라한 주식 계좌 봤거든요
보고 나서 제가 얘기했죠
가려라
가려라 이건
가려야지
회계사님이 진짜 본업으로 굉장히
우리나라 불지의 회계법인 대표
대표신데
이거는 지장이 있겠다
저도 그렇게 얘기를 했었습니다
제가 차마 얘기를 안 했을 뿐이지
예전에 코로나 오기 전까지는
수익률이 엄청났어요
엄청나고
누가요?
제가요 제가
자 본인 얘기
사실 우리 또 회계사님
샤워자라는 별명이 지금 붙었습니다
아침에 샤워할 때
유튜브에 리딩방 이런 거 있잖아요
방송 이후에 혹시 주변에 반응이 있으셨나요?
제 아주 친한 거래처 사장님이 계신데
그 사장님이 유튜버를 한 명 추천을 해줬어요
그래서 제가 다른 유튜버들 다 손절하고
그분 한 분으로 올인하는 걸로
그분이 추천하는 것만 사요 이제
그분이 종목 집어주세요?
그렇죠 집어주죠
종목 얻으려면 혹시 돈을 내야 되나요?
돈을 안 내도 되는데
뭐 좋아요
그다음에 쿠팡도 뭘 누르라 그러고
잠깐만 뭘 누르라 그래요?
구독자가 아니네
주변에 사기 피해자가 왜 생기는지를
아 쿠팡을 눌러요?
너무나 명확하게 알 수 있다
여러분 그 변호사라고 사기 안 당하고
회계사라고 숫자에 강할 것 같죠?
거의 한 30년 이렇게 보면
아니야 내가 걱정이 돼
그 유튜버를 추천해 준 사장님은
저를 진짜 좋아해요
좋아하겠죠 골드형 뭐 저걸 다인데
안 좋아하겠어요?
그래서 진심으로 추천을 해주셔서
그래서 저는 그 사장님을 믿어요
아 성과가 되게 좋았다고 제가 말해요
아 좋지는 않아요
아직은 믿고 있어요
아직은?
아직은 믿고 있다고
서울대 경제학과 정보가 이렇게 도는군요
큰일입니다
우리나라 회계 법인의 앞날이 어두워요 지금
돈업을 잘 하시니까 괜찮지 않을까
돈은 일해서 벌어야 된다
이런 명언도 사실 남겨주셨어요
그래서 제가 열심히 일했어요
메꾸려고 주식 메꾸려고
아니 근데 지난번에 나오시고 나서
댓글이 막 300개 400개가 달렸는데
댓글 중에 이제 보면서 느낀
이 아저씨들도 직업만 다르지
나랑 똑같은 사람들이었구나
엄청 공감을 많이 해주셨어요
서울대 경제학과는 막 엄청난 차트로 보고
막 이럴 줄 알았는데
그냥 우리랑 똑같이 유튜브 보고
제가 보니까 그렇게 하면 더 안 되는 거 같아
제 경험상은
제가 지금까지 제일 많이 벌었던 종목
그때 제가 상한가를 4번 먹었나?
4번?
100%
100% 넘었죠 30% 해가지고
그러니까 그런 식으로
제가 뭐 책을 본 것도 아니고
공부를 한 것도 아니고
경제학과에서 공부하셨잖아요
공부 안 해서요
그런 거랑은 전혀 주식하고는
제가 보니까 전혀 관련이 없어요
그런 식으로 했을 때가 이제 성적이 정말 좋았고
근데 이제 저도 좀 불안하니까
이게 이 맞나?
맨날 이렇게 벌긴 버는데
이 방법이 맞나 싶어서
이제 20년도부터는 보고서도 좀 봐보고
오 레포트 레포트
애널리스트 보고서 보고 물린 게 5G
저랑 같이 많이 하는 변호사가 있는데
그분도 좀 크게 하시는데
제 수익을 보여줬더니 바로 달려들었거든요
안 하다가
이거 뭐야 이러더니
그분이 굉장히 연구하는 스타일이어가지고
막 보고서를 엄청 보내주는 거예요
그런 식으로 해서
그 당시에 5G를 21년도 1월 달쯤에
온갖 보고서를 자기도 보고 나한테도 보내주는 거예요
그걸 보면은 실은 안 살 수가 없어
논리적으로 안 살 수가 없는 주식이야
그때도 되게 많이 올랐을 때인데
이제 시작이라는 거예요 보고서에 따르면
많이 나오는 말이죠 이제 시작
이제 시작이래요
이게 깔려야 앞으로 무슨 자율주행이든 이런 게 다 기본이다
고속도로나 똑같다 2% 하기 때문에
이제 시작이라는 거예요
그래서 그런 보고서 보고 샀다가
그분하고 저하고 지금까지 21년도 1월부터
지금 몇 년째야?
종목이 혹시
KMW랑 다산네트웍스
KMW랑 다산네트웍스 아직도 물려계세요 그거?
물려있죠
지금 5년 몇 개월째
저도 그거 물려가지고 좀 힘들었거든요
아직도 손절 안 하셨어요 근데?
아니 손절을 못하죠
지금 6G로 넘어가고 있는데
5G 건너뛴 줄 알았네요
지금 6G 오고 있어요
2030년 6G 얘기하시던데
그러니까
그러니까는 뭐야
KMW가 8만 3...
6,000원에서 물렸는데
6,000원까지 떨어졌었거든요
6,000원으로 왔다고요?
6,000원까지 떨어졌었어요
마이너스 90%인 거 같은데?
누나한테 좀 미안하긴 한데
누나한테도 권유를
누나 돈입니까?
아니 누나한테도 소개해줘서
저번에 말씀드렸던 오세훈 시장 테마주
물렸던 누나한테도
그때가 20년도 겨울인가인데
보일러가 고장나가지고
누나네 집에 하루 저희가 갔는데
그때가 하필이면 제가 그걸 많이 샀을 때여서
누나한테 되게 고마운 마음에 얘기를 해줬더니
누나가 바로 샀어요
아 그때 보일러가 고장이 안 났어야 되는데
그러니까 하루 재워졌는데 그게 그냥 손실이
미안하죠 미안하네
그런데 올해 6월달인가?
무슨 주파수 경매 한다고 그래가지고
네? 주파수 경매?
미국에서 무슨 주파수 경매를 한다고 해서 오른다던데요?
모르겠어요
우리나라 기업인데 미국에서 주파수 경매를
아니 아니 미국에서 무슨 주파수 경매를 하면
이 회사가 수혜를 받는다고 해서
지금 막 쿵쾅쿵쾅 한다고
혹시 요즘에 광통신 오르는 거는 조금 아세요?
어...
저는 제 종목 아니면 관심력이...
그러니까 광통신?
아직도 5G에요 지금 계셔
아 5G를 건넌 게 광통신이에요?
아니 뭐 그건 아니죠
그리고 다산네트워크는 또
광통신이고 나발이고 다산네트워크
우크라이나 재건 수혜주로 또 묶여가지고
5,510원
그 본인
13,000 얼마
아! 지금 2,300원까지 빠졌네?
아니 다산네트워크 2,300원이에요?
아니 아니 아니 놀래지 마 놀래지 마
2,300원까지 빠졌어
지금 5,500원이에요?
어 왜 이렇게 놀래
5,000원쯤 했던 것 같은데
깜짝 놀랐네요
저는 실은 5G 때문에 한 4년간 주식을 안 했어요
아니 대단하네요
마이너스 90%를 어떻게 버텼습니까?
어떻게 버티지?
그렇게 떨어진 줄 몰랐어요
안 보니까
알겠습니다
우리 사실 회계사님도 실온소닉도 계시고
물려있는 것도 있는데
가장 크게 물려있는 건 혹시 어떤 쪽이실까요?
벙거 얘기해도 돼요
가장 크게 벙거
벙거 얘기하셔도 돼요
벙거는 한화비전이 많이 벌었어요
한화비전 혹시 그 유튜버한테 받은 종목?
그렇죠
그 유튜버한테 받은 것 중에 제일 많이 깨진 종목은 뭡니까 그럼?
종목은 잘 모르겠어요
아 종목은 모른다고?
근데 저는 다 플러스 될 거라고 생각해요
믿음 맺어요
왜 왜 이유는 뭡니까?
제가 좀 낙천적인 것 같아요
아니 종목을 모르던데
아니 그러니까 종목을 굳이 알 필요가 없는 게
빨간색으로 플러스가 되면
근데 실현하면 되잖아요
제가 사실 회계사님 종목을 보면서
제가 그래도 국장 좀 빠꾸미거든요
근데 진짜 생전 처음 들어본 종목들 밖에 없어요
한번 공개 한번 해 주실까요?
우리 회계사님 계좌 두 개를 총 준비를 해 주셨어요
하나는
광스템 바이오텍도 저는 처음 봤는데
이게 아토피 치료제 3상으로 간 종목이더라고요
그래요?
저건 왜 사는 주식이에요?
그거 만 원 간다고 그래 가지고
또 누가 만 원 간다고 그래서?
그리고 넥스틴 같은 경우도 저도 저건 처음 들어와 가지고 찾아봤는데
이게 반도체 웨이퍼 검사 장비더라고요
되게 다양하게 사시네요 바이오 2차전지 반도체
반도체가 잘 나가잖아요
그럼 그 번 돈을 장비에 투자할 거다
그럼 누가 얘기해 줬습니까?
그거는 이제
유튜버?
유튜버
아 유튜버가
자 그리고 두 번째 계좌
잠깐만요 왼쪽은 실연소득이니까 판 거고
오른쪽은 지금 포트폴리오 갖고 있는 거잖아요
지금 쓰레기들 많아
형 딱 보니까 플러스나면 팔고
마이너스나 쓰레기들만 주식장고로
원래 다 빨갰을 때 파는 거 아닌가요?
원래 어떻게 다 어떻게 하시는 거예요?
파란색은 어떻게 해요?
파란색 가득 있어야죠
빨간색 갤 때까지?
그렇죠
그렇죠?
나 그거 되게 좋은 방법 같은데요?
그렇지 않아요?
포트폴리오에 개쓰레기만 모으는 거잖아요
아니 이게 슈타님은 이해를 못 하시니까
이게 사실 평균적인 줄이니 계좌 아닙니까?
아니 줄이니가 아니라 나는 되게 합리적으로
아 이게 합리적이에요?
오르면 팔고 줄 때 빨리 팔아서 먹고
물리면 기다리고
시간은 우리 편이잖아요
근데 우리 유튜버 선생님은 저 종목들을 길목을 지킨다?
뭐 이런 표현을 쓰시더라고요
길목을 지킨다
길목을 너무 오래 지키고 있는데?
나무가는 지금 마이너스 30%거든요
나무가는 제가 어떤 종목인지 몰랐는데
여기 출연하려고 좀 봤어요
네 네
로봇의 가장 중요한 게 눈이라고 하더라고요
로봇의 눈을 만드는 회사다
근데 왜 본인에게 오신게 있던 거잖아요
근데 왜 몰랐어요 있는지?
근데 종목이
제가 원래 몇 개였냐면
저는 13개를 항상 가지고 있어요
왜그러냐면
이순신 장군이
13척으로
12척?
12척이었다가
어디서
맞다 맞다 대장선이 하나
하나 더 봤어
이순신 장군 몇 명 보입니까?
맞아 맞아 맞아
그 정도 딱 가지고 있어요 그 다음에 계좌는 항상 고수들처럼 두 개로 딱
하익진 좌익 우익을 펼친 그 하익진 의 모습으로
사실 저는 좀 의아한 거는 유일로보틱스 나무가 저거 전부 다 로봇이잖아요
근데 로봇이 잘 갔거든요 근데 어떻게 마이너스 30%가
이게 호르무즈 뭐 이런 거랑 관계 있나요
관계 있냐고 호르무즈
몰라요 저 잘 유일로보틱스하고 나무가는 어떻게
살게 되셨습니까 유튜버가
유튜버가 이 놈의 유튜버가 진짜
이 중에서 네이버 하나만 지난번에 방송에서 효재형이
좋다고 해가지고 샀거든요 아니 좋다고 안 했어
그때 이후로 물린 겁니까 네 그날 이후로 분할매수했어요
하루에 100만원씩 분할매수 안 했으면 큰일 날 뻔했네
그리고 제가 삼성전자도 있었죠 슈카님이 삼성이랑
내가 사라는 건 다 플러스 익절했네요 익절했어요
다 익절하고 아니 근데 다른 거보다 정말 이해가 안 되는 게
빨간색은 다 팔고 물린 거는 다 처리
그렇게 두는 게 저렇게 되면 포트폴리오가 안 좋은 종목들로만
쫙 구성되는 거잖아요 물린 종목이 안 좋은 건 아니지
어우 그래 어우 이거 날카로웠다 그럼요 저평가된 것을 시간을 투자해서
기다리고 있는 물린 거로
관점을 바꿔야지 그치 꽃은 뽑고 잡초에 물을 주는
그렇죠 아니 그렇죠 거꾸로 얘기한 거
잡초는 근데 이거를 슈카님이 특정 시점에
계좌를 딱 달라고 해서 계좌를 까니까 저렇게 나오지
이걸 딱 들였을 때가 이란이랑 미국이랑
호르무즈 그렇죠 그래서 이게 어떻게 될지 모르는
그런 상황이었어요 그래서 그날 내가 효재 형한테 전화했거든요
근데 주식 안 한다 그랬는데 주식 참고 있어
참고 있어 그리고 이게 방송이 있으니까 좋은
모습을 좀 보여주고 싶어서 그래서 요새는 아예 좀 안 하고 있어요
아니 그 모습을 보여주려고 하면 이럴까 봐 요새
아니 근데 지금 사실 효재 변호사 님 피해자들이 등장하고 있습니다
회계사님도 하루 100만 원씩 잡초 에 물을 주고 계시고
보시는 분들 중에도 네이버에 효재 변호사님 좋다 그래가지고 네이버
올려 계신 분이 네이버 근데 이제 바닥을 이제 다질 때가 돼서
저도 이제 관심을 조금 바닥을 다 지고 있다
다질 때가 된 거 같다 아니 근데 네이버가 바닥을 다지고
있다는 근거는 혹시 있으세요
요번에 주총에서 난리 났었다고 그러는데
주총에서 왜요 무슨 일이 있었죠 주주들이 막 엄청 화내고 막
더운 게 아니잖아요 그거 아니 그러니까 이제
정보로 난리가 나야지 난리가 나서 이제 대표님이 뭐 자사주
소각을 한다는 거 맞아요 뭐 할 거다 뭐 이런 거였나
그리고 아무튼 저 주가 관리에 신경 좀 쓰겠다
자사주 소각을 한다는 거 맞아요 자사주 소각을 한다는 거 맞아요
자사주 소각하면 올라가요 올라가죠 자사주 소각하면
올라가 올라가 저 회계사 아니세요
아니 저는 진짜 그래서 뭐 자사주 소각하라고 이런
말 안 하십니까 근데 자사주는 이미 내가 들고 있는
거 아니에요 이미 들고 있는 거를 형은 그냥 회계
열심히 하자 회계 보면 열심히 하는 게 좋을 거
같아요 얼굴 가리고 나오시길 다행이다
형 마스크 좀 올려봐 위로 마스크 좀 올려봐
더 안 보이게 더 안 보이게 안 되겠어 안 되겠어
눈까지 가려도 자사주를 가지고 있으면 그럼 그거는
자산입니까 자본입니까 자본이죠
그럼 검색해봐 요즘에 너무 AI가 너무
하죠 하죠 하죠 마지막에 지키고
네 알겠습니다 이렇게 또 회계사님 한번 보셨고
우리 이효재 변호사님 계좌가 가장 너무 궁금해가지고
사실 그런 반응이 있었어요 부국증권 신용증권 올랐어요
막 다들 난리가 나가지고 다 익절했어요
신용증권은 진짜 고점 29만 몇천 원인가 찍었었거든요
27만 원에 팔았어요 고수다 지금 20만 원이거든요
근데 부국증권은 많이 못 먹었어요 부국증권은 진짜 이해가 안 가는
게 아침에 20 몇 프로 올라가지고
아침에 보면 팔까 봐 안 보거든요 거의 안 보는데
20 몇 프로 아침에 올랐으니까 그래서 궁금해서 한 3시 근처쯤
이제 끝나기 전에 한번 봤더니 2%인가 3%밖에 안 오른 거예요
다 떨어졌어 그래서 딱 뭐 왜 이렇게 20 몇 프로
갔던 게 2%까지 떨어졌지 그래서 봤더니만
이대주주가 무슨 케이프증권인가 계속 팔고 있는 거예요 그날
아 진짜로 이대주주가 그래서 야 이거는 뭐가
있나 보다 우리가 모르는 뭐가 있나 보다 하고
파는데 와 이거 진짜 제가 신용으로 많이 샀잖아요
그건 신용이 돼서 신용이 많이 돼 신용으로 샀어요 변호사가 주식을 신용으로 샀어요
신용되면 사야죠 그것도 능력인데 신용 그냥 아무나 해주는 건 아니니까
신용 받으려면 어떻게 해야 돼요 조건이 있어요
거기 눌러보면 신용되면은 그냥
아 눌러보면 있어요 주는 대로 주는 대로
저는 항상 살 때 신용이 되는 일단 신용으로 사봐요
아니 한 줄을 사는데 신용을 누르면
자기 현금이 있는데도 일단 신용 으로
아 무조건 현금은 있고 왜 왜 왜
아 그 이유 알 것 같아요 현금은 항상 보유하라고 하잖아요
현금을 항상 보유하라고 신용으로 사면 어떡해요
현금 비중 30% 유지가 안 돼서 아니 그리고 그게 또 제가 왜 그렇게 안 되는지 모르겠는데
현금을 항상 보유하라고 신용으로 사면 어떡해요 현금 비중 30% 유지가 안 돼서
자 그리고 이게 또 제가 왜 그렇게 안 되냐면 이게 신용이 되는지
신용이 초과돼서 안 되는 거는 아 사람들이 신용으로 많이 샀으니까 몰렸구나
과연 지금 신용이 되는 종목인지
에 뭐 그런
신용이 많이 몰려있으면 아 이게 되게 핫한 주식이구나
그럼 이제 신용으로 몰려서 다 살 만큼 핫하구나
머리털하고 처음 들어 봤어요
어 이게 무슨 말이에요
근데 신용은 어떻게 사는 거예요
현금 있고 신용 있으면 신용 눌러서 사지는 거는 사지고
그치 신용이 안 되는 종목이 있어요
신용이 안 되는 그렇죠 신용이 안 되는 종목은
이게 다 다 다가갔죠
별로 좋은 주식이 아닌 거예요
그 뭐 착주는 신용 잘 안돼요
우량주를 판단하는 근거가 될 수가 있고
그 다음에 현재 사람들이 신용을 많이 샀는지
신용이 초과됐는지 아닌지
여기 미수라고 하는게 신용이에요?
아니 미수는 아니에요 미수는 나도 안해봐서
미수까진 안해보셨어요
형은 그냥 mtc 지우면 될 것 같아
한 번도 안해보셨어요?
신용이요?
네
전 머리털려고 신용 한 번도 안해봤어요
왜 안하지?
그러게
아니 현금으로 사요
아니 현금은 놔두고
현금은 왜 놔두는 거야
현금은 왜 놔둬요 현금을
현금은 왜 놔두냐면
현금은 코코 150 레버리지는 현금밖에 안돼요
아 레버리지 하려고 돈을 아껴두는 거예요?
그렇죠
얘는 신용으로 살 수 있으니까 신용으로 그거 하고
코코 150 레버리지 지금 이제 계속 눈여겨보고 있는데
그거를 기회가 올 때까지 하려고 이렇게 딱
기회를 엿보고 있는 거예요
신용하면 대출 이자 내야 되잖아요
이자 뭐 얼마 안되는 거
몰라요
얼마인지 모르시잖아요
모르죠 얼마 그거 얼마인지 모르는데
그렇게 해서 얼마인데
아 부국증권이 그래서 신용으로 산다 이거 처음 알았어요
딱 파는데 안 팔려요
왜 왜 왜
아니 그게 저도 이번에 처음 알았는데
신용을 다섯 번 이상을 사면 하나씩 눌러서 팔아야 되나봐요
원래는 신용은 딱
무슨 말이에요 그게
다섯 번 저도 몰랐어요
무슨 말이에요
이제 팔려고 신용으로 해서 딱 파는데 안 팔려
계속 뭐라고 뭐가 떠요
뭐라고 떠는데요
뭐가 뭐 다섯 번 이상이면 뭐가 안 된다는 식으로
그래서 안 팔려 그래서 나는 빨리 팔아야 되는데
어떻게 팔았는지도
어떻게 했는지 모르겠어요 근데
어떻게 했는지 모르겠다고요
꿈꾸신 거 아니에요
아무튼 이제 날짜가 다르게 다섯 번
그게 맞아요 대출 일자가 달라서 그래요
네 그래서 하나씩 하나씩 뭐를 눌러서 팔아야 되더라고요
근데 이게 진짜 중요한 건 뭐냐면
개미들이 생각보다 신용을 많이 해요
근데 이걸 그냥 덮어놓고 신용하지 마세요라고 하면 안 하냐고
이거를 정확하게 우리가 알고
하든지 안 하든지 선택은 개인이 하는 거죠
그럼 뭘 정확하게 하는지 모르겠는데 뭘 뭘
신용 다섯 번
증권주는 근데 너무 타이밍 좋게 잘 파셨다
그때가 고점이긴 했거든요 파셨을 때가
고수니까요
그래서 이 정도만 만족하고 뭐 더 가면 내 몫이 아니다 생각하고
뭐야 고수 고수의 향기
그러면 우리 고수님의 계절을 한 번 볼 텐데 공개해도 되는 건지 모르겠습니다
왜 왜 왜
어 수량이 나오네 수량이 나오네 아니 아니 수량이
금액을 지었는데 수량이 나오면 이거
금액은 지어주신다는데 수량이 나오면 어떡해요
금액은 지어준대 틀린 말은 아니네
수량 지워 수량 지워
수량 지워서 오게 되려나
수량 지워 내려내려내려
금액은 지워냈지
금액은 지웠네
아이고야
아 뒷골은
지금 제일 많이 갖고 계신 게 코스닥 150 레버리지 갖고 계시잖아요
근데 지금 최근에 코스닥 150 레버리지 안 좋아요
계속 갖고 계실 생각이신가요 아니면 조금
요즘 반도체 좋으니까 반도체로 갈아타실 수도 있잖아요
아니 반도체는 리노공업하고
아 리노공업
워닝가이피스라고 반도체 소부장
아 근데 물렸어요 그거 다
네
반도체에 물렸어요
요번에 샀죠 요번에
아
원래 이제 전쟁 나고 나서 안 하려고 그랬는데 봤더니 3월 12일 날 다 샀더라고요. 근데 그날 왜 올랐을까?
아무튼 막 올랐어요. 워닝 아이피스랑 리노공업이 전쟁보다도 오히려 더 올랐어요. 계속 올랐어요. 반도체라서.
전쟁이 터졌는데도 이게 오히려 떨어지지 않고 오르는 종목이면 정말 좋은 주식이구나. 잘 버티는구나.
그래서 그날 아침에 그 두 개가 한 십몇% 올랐던 것 같아요. 반도체 소부장이 되게 좋다고 해서 십몇% 올라서 들어갔는데 그날부터 다 빠졌어요.
아니, 십몇% 올린 걸 들어갔어요?
오르고 나서 오르면서.
강출량이네요.
그러니까 이제는 올랐을 때, 빨간불일 때는 안 들어가려고.
파란불일 때?
네, 파란불.
50 평생 드디어 깨달으셨군요.
꼬셔진 것 같아요. 그날 이렇게 빨간불로 진짜 빨간불일 때는 가지 말아야 되겠다.
우리 유튜버 선생님은 아침에 빨간불일 때는 들어가는 게 아니라
그거는 맞아.
아, 그래요?
왜?
왜냐하면 빨간불이면 이미 다 올라가 있어요. 거기서는 이제 먹을 게 별로 없고.
아침에 파란불일 때 들어가는 거예요?
그...
그렇게 싫은데요?
잘 모르면 어떻게 해?
빨간불 아니면 파란불인데. 빨간불일 때 안 들어가면 파란불 때 들어가는 소리잖아요.
자, 우리 피디님이 다시 보여주세요.
그러면 저기서 가장 많이 본 건 이미 뺐기 때문에 없는 거죠?
그렇죠. 신영증권, 부국증권은 한 주만 넣어놨고.
근데 저기 보니까 삼성전자, 하이닉스는 하나도 없네요?
아니, 그건 원래 삼성전자와 하이닉스는 안 샀었어요. 한 주만 샀었답니다.
삼성전자가 예전에도.
아니, 왜 한 주를 왜 사요? 정찰병.
정찰병.
정찰병. 그래도 항상 관심은 갖고 싶다.
아, 그럼 관심 용목 등록해 놓으면 뜨잖아요. 그렇게 안 보여서.
그러니까. 왜 한 주를 사냐고, 삼성전자를.
근데 그게 있어요. 무슨 말인지 너무 아는 게 정찰병 보내는 이유는 내가 이걸로 돈을 벌면 좋지만 10만 원이라도 들어가 있어야 이게 내 관심을 갖고 보지.
그러니까 몇 퍼센트 떨어졌다.
맞아요. 맞아요. 맞아요.
내 기준점에 어떤. 그게 플러스, 마이너스를 해주니까.
그게 무슨 말이에요? 그게 도대체 무슨 말이야?
현실 감각이 없어.
현실 감각이?
그러니까 내가 가지고 있다는 생각이 안 드니까 관심이 덜해지는 거죠.
그렇죠.
뭐.
설득되냐?
혹시 관심 종목 등록하는 법 모르셔서 사시는 건 아니시죠?
관심 종목?
응.
어떻게 등록하는 거야?
어떻게.
에이, 그건 알.
그건 에이.
나도 아는데.
그게 무슨 말이지?
따님한테 좀.
무슨 말이냐고?
관심 종목 등록한다? 그게 무슨 말인지 제가 이해를 잘 못 해요.
법법이 다릅니다.
근데 신기한 게 세명전기는 거의 86%인데.
저거는 어떻게.
그냥 냅두셨어요?
안 팔고?
아마 저거 한 주인데 2000년쯤에.
2000년에 샀다고?
네.
아니, 아니.
2000년이 아니라 2020년입니다.
2020년?
네.
2020년에 아마 한 주.
한 주.
그럼 저 종목 중에 제일 많이 들고 있는 거는 뭐예요?
아, 코코 150 레버리지.
빼고.
두 번째 많이 산 건 뭐예요?
저거 KMW 다산 네트워크 수는 워낙 이제 오래된.
진짜 미안합니다.
그러니까요.
저는 진짜 제 주식들을 저의 병사.
제가 사령관이고 내가 병사라고 생각하는데 너무 오랫동안 묶여있어가지고
포로로 5년 몇 개월을.
포로로 샹을 하고 있는 거죠?
네.
미안해요.
너무 미안해요.
누구한테 미안한 거예요?
저 병사들한테.
아, 저 주식들한테.
아니, 저분들이 병사님한테 미안해해야 되는 거 아니에요?
저의 사령관의 판단 미수로 저렇게 몇 년간 지금.
아, 저 PHA라는 것이.
저 뭐예요?
PHA?
무슨 현대차의 부품을 납품한다고 하더라고요.
아, 저 종목 보면 주식이 세력들이 갖고 노는 약간.
왜 또 왜?
왜?
아니, 저 종목이.
저게 현대차가.
아, 그러니까 딱 정황적인.
아, 정황적인.
제가 들어갔는데 현대차가 많이 오르고 관련주들이 많이 오를 때인데
저 주식이 아침에 시작하자마자 막 20몇 %로 시작하는 거예요.
프로 수로.
그래가지고 뭐지 하고는 이렇게 찾아봤어요.
그랬더니 현대차에 납품하는 회사인데 매출이 막 1조 넘어 영업이익이
막 매년 500억씩 나오고요.
그런데 시총이 막 2천억 대밖에 안 돼요.
그래서 야, 이게 뭐야.
뭐 이렇게 좋은 회사가 시총이 말이 돼?
그런데 그날 아침에 20몇 %로 시작해서 내가 잠깐 찾아보는 사이에 상한가를
가 있어요.
어머, 그러면 미치지.
네.
그래서 일단 상가로 넣어놨어요.
아, 걸어놨다.
걸어놨어요.
그래가지고는 제가 걸어놓고는 이거 사주면 정말 좋겠다라고 했는데
그때 잔량이 3천 몇백만 주셨어요.
아, 이거 뭐 안 사지겠지 하고 이제 샤워하고 이제 출근하려고 샤워
딱 했는데 나와보니까 사줬어.
사줬어.
나는 걸어놓고 사주면 정말 좋겠다 했는데 이렇게까지 바란 건 아닌데
이게 막.
이게 진짜 사줬어.
아니, 그리고 막 거래량이 엄청 터지면서 그날, 그날 상한가였는데
한 마이너스 20몇 %인가?
네?
그러니까 쭉.
마이너스 50%가 난 거네요.
하루에.
아니, 아니.
결국 종가가 한 10%로 끝났나?
어.
그러니까 나는 마이너스 20%죠.
그 정도.
차트 한 번 잠깐 보여주세요.
네.
전화를.
저 피레칭 날.
아, 피레칭.
그러면은 가격, 산 가격이 15,600원 더.
네.
좀 위에서 산 거네요?
그렇죠.
그렇다고요?
그래서 지금 물려있구나.
그렇게 된 건데.
근데 뭐 보니까 회사는 너무 좋은 회사여서 그 PBR이 0.3이고 PER이
500원.
아니, 그게 이런 건 어떻게 또 공부를 다 하셨어요?
아니, 보세요.
매출이 막 1조가 넘어.
네.
이게 매년.
이게 한 번이 아니라 매년 500억씩 나는데 지금 시총이 2천억대가
2천억대.
이게 말이 되냐.
그런 종목 많긴 한데.
많아요?
우리나라 국장은 반년 전까지 평균 PBR이 1이 안 됐기 때문에.
그러니까 정부에서 요번에.
아, 정부.
정부 정부.
아니, 근데 사실 지난번에 나오셨을 때 우리 이호재 변호사님이 굉장히
또 스타가 되셔가지고 업적 5개를 우리 댓글로 정리를 해주셨습니다.
1.
유료 리딩방.
2.
고퍼스 존버.
3.
비트마인 매수.
4.
보호.
5.
7곡 산삼액 120만원 플라시보.
나눔.
정치 테마주도 들고 계세요?
그때 한가 쩜아 두 번 맞고.
와, 이거 역사다.
쩜아를 두 번을 먹어요?
두 번 맞았어요.
두 번 맞고.
와, 어떡하냐.
저희 와이프가 주식을 원래 안 하는 사람인데.
네.
제 얘기 듣고.
아.
사가지고 바로 국장 은퇴.
바로 은퇴했어?
국장.
일주일 만에 은퇴.
아, 이건 진짜.
국장은 아닌 것 같아.
그러면서 이제.
미장.
미장이 좋다.
응.
또 유튜버야?
또 유튜버다.
저도 미장은 안 했으니까 몰랐는데.
이제 여기저기 찾아봐서 뭐 구독자가 많은 거 해서 두 군데를 알려줬어요
.
구독자가 여기에 제일 많은데.
아무리 옆에서 얘기해줘도 안 들어.
옆에 슈퍼가 있는데 슈퍼가를 듣는 사람이 아무도 없어요.
그래가지고 유튜버를 줬더니.
저는 안 봤는데.
네.
되게 열심히 하더라고요.
근데 이제 공부를 좀 하더니.
지금이 뭘 사도 싸다.
근데 이제 공부를 그때 처음 시작하는 거니까.
그때 샀으면 되는데.
공부를 열심히 막 너무 오래 해.
한 4개월 하더라고요.
4개월.
하고 내놓은 게 비트마인이에요.
아.
최초의 종목.
공부 4개월 하고 비트마인이라는 결론을 얻었습니까.
그거 9월달인가?
높을 때 샀어요.
한 3주 하고 은퇴.
또 미장에서 또?
미장 은퇴.
그럼 코인으로 가셨나?
코인도 그때 같이 샀죠.
비트마인 살 때 코인.
같이 샀어?
같이 사서.
그러면은 최근에 또 지방선거 앞두고 있잖아요.
아 또 선거 테마주 또 하시려고?
정치 테마주가 돌아오거든요.
이제 그때 느낀 게 정치 테마주는 못하겠다.
제 경험상.
6월달에 지방선거가 있으면 그 전에 훨씬 더 전에 정치 테마주는 훨씬
빨리.
그거 제 손에 있으면 한 1년 전에 부터 막 날라가고 그거 지나면 이제
완전히.
그러면은 최근에는 주식을 앞으로 조금 어떻게 하겠다.
왜냐면 지금 오늘도 주식창 안 보셔 가지고 얼마나 올랐는지도 모르시
잖아요.
그러니까요.
저는 지금은 조금 기다리려고.
미국하고 이란 전쟁이 조금 어느 정도 마무리가 되면 제가 보니까
확신을 가져도 잘 잃더라고요.
그래서 잘 모를 때는 안 하는 게 맞는 것 같아요.
아 잘 모르니까.
감망해 감망.
조금 떠나 있다가 이제 기회가 되면 그래도 제일 좋게 보는 건 저는 코코
150 레벨이었습니다.
그거 지금.
아니 거기 왜 굳이 레버리지를 넣었어요 그냥 한 배짜리 해도 되는데.
한 배짜리요.
네.
아유 그거 너무 재미없죠.
재미없.
아유 그거 할 거면 삼성전자 사지.
아유 말이 통한다 이제.
삼성전자 요새야 많이 올랐지 예전에는 뭐 한 20% 1년에 20%도 잘
안 올랐.
1년에 20%면 대박이잖아요.
그렇게 사람이 포부가 적어서야 되겠습니까.
우리 그런 스타일 아니잖아요.
그러니까.
우리 그런 스타일 아니거든요.
아 그렇지.
회계사님도.
저는 바뀌었어요.
바뀌었어요.
저는 예전에는 진짜 1,000원 이상 주식은 잘 안 했거든요.
1,000원이 이상 주식.
그러니까 한 주당 1,000원.
동전주.
아 동전주 넣는 걸 안 했다.
진짜 안 했다.
장난 아니에요.
아 500원짜리만 하세요.
그러니까 1,000원 넘으면 어우 이거 너무 비싸니까.
잘 안 올라갔으면 무거운 주식이잖아요.
무거운 주식이다.
그래서 안 했는데 요즘에는 진짜 제가 지난 방송 나오고 정말 많이
바뀌었어요.
어떻게 어떻게.
이제 한 2,000원짜리 합니까 이제.
이제는 거의 20만 원짜리도 있고.
20만 원짜리도.
그리고 이제 우량주만 하려고요.
지난 번에도 제가 잡주 비중이 거의 90% 정도 됐는데 이제 안 하려고
했어요.
유튜버가 알려주면 어떻게 할 거예요.
그 선생님 그런 분 아닙니다.
야 무슨 소리 하는 거야.
그런 분 아닙니다.
그 선생님.
그 선생님 아까 모르는 주식만 잔뜩 있더만 뭘.
아니에요.
그렇게 생각하지 마세요.
뭐라고요.
그 선생님 욕하지 마세요.
아니 근데 그 선생님이 왜 그렇게 좋으세요.
왜 샤워할 때 맨날 틀어놓으세요.
제가 귀가 굉장히 얇아요.
그래서 뭘 추천만 하면 무조건 사거든요.
근데 이분은 추천을 잘 안 해.
한 3일 정도 샤워를 하면 한 종목 정도 나오는 거예요.
아 가뭄에 꽂고.
가뭄에 꽂고.
저랑 잘 맞아.
애태운다.
아니 근데 슈카님도 그래도 종목 자주 얘기해 주시잖아요.
어디서 슈카월드에서 방송에서.
뭘 봐야 알지요.
뭘 봐야.
그래서 제 비중이 사실 삼성전자랑 하이닛에서 제일 많죠.
슈카 덕분에.
네이버는 형 덕분이고.
네이버 오릅니다.
3년만 기다리시면.
3년?
그냥 딴 거 하면 안 돼요.
왜 3년이나 기다려야 돼요.
3년이나 기다려야 돼요.
아까 뭐 도파민 뭐 하더니 3년이나 기다려야 됩니까 이건.
그러니까.
밸런스가 전체가 있으면 좀 안정적인 것도 좀 있어야 되고 과감하게 하는
것도.
도파민도 있어야 되고.
안정적인 거는 네이버다.
3년 안에는 오른다.
계좌 두 개니까.
하나는 장기 계좌 하나는 단기 계좌.
아니 그 고수가 그렇게 해요.
선생님이 그렇게 하라고.
네 그렇죠.
그걸 투자 계좌라고 하죠 투자 계좌.
그럼 이거는 나머지 하나는 뭐라고 하죠.
뭐예요.
그냥.
종목 계좌.
제가 줄인이거든요.
네.
투자하는 어떤 마음가짐을 좀 바꾸 기를 했어요.
어떻게 어떻게.
사람이 이제 위험 회피적이라고 하잖아요.
네.
위험 중립적으로 생각하자.
와 서울대.
와.
그래서 잃어도 따도 너무 슬퍼하거나 기뻐하지 말자.
그런 말이에요.
맞아 맞아 맞아.
되게 중요한 거야.
형상심이 중요한 거야.
그렇지.
따도 기뻐하지 말자가 아니라 잃어도 슬퍼하지 말자 쪽에 조금
더.
그렇지 그렇지.
아니 수양을 많이 하게 돼.
휴식을 하면.
지금 서울대 경제학과에 어떤.
네.
퀄리티.
많이 놀라고 있습니다.
그럼 안 돼요 안 돼요.
안 돼요.
학교에서 연락 오면.
우리가 전체를.
대표하지 않으세요.
대표한다고 생각하면 절대 안 돼요.
아니 근데 주식은 제가 보니까 진짜 뛰어난 분들도 대부분 잃어요
.
제가 보니까 주식.
아니 왜.
게임이기 때문에.
대부분 잃고.
그럼 누가 따.
누가 따.
세력이.
합리적인 분들이 잘 못 따는 것 같아요.
비합리적인 사람이 따는 겁니까.
그러니까 이제 좀.
그럼 변호사님 보신 분 중에 제일 많이 딴 사람.
동문 뭐 동기 위아래 잘하시는 분 없습니까.
그러니까.
제가 조금 잘하지.
아.
성원의 경제학과.
학과의 명예를 실추시키세요.
최고 아웃풋.
슈카가 잘하죠.
슈카가 뭐.
20년부터 맨날 삼성전자 하이닉스.
종목 연구 좀 해오세요.
맨날.
그게 제일 많이 갔잖아요.
그게.
맨날 삼성전자.
아니 막 상한가하고 이런 것 좀 하다 쯤.
아니 그때가 ai 시대 딱 나오는 데 기 때문에 좀 있으면 반도차 간다
고.
그 얘기 맨날 했던 건데.
그러면 지금 이때까지는 삼전하이닉스였고 앞으로 이제 슈카가 주목하는 거.
우리 하나 던져줘요.
맞아요 맞아요.
좀 변동성 큰 걸로.
지금.
변동적이야.
그러니까 변동성 큰 걸로.
천천히 오르는 거 말고.
재밌는 걸로.
오늘 하이닉스 8% 움직였어요.
아이 그 정도.
그 정도 안 돼.
그 정도.
아 1억도 뭐예요.
한 3개월 안에 완전히 날아갈 수.
아니 반도차에 딱 붙었어야지 지금.
반도차.
왜 딱 보여 붙어.
또 하이닉스예요.
또 삼전이야.
아니 지금 답답해 죽겄네.
저는 조금 궁금한 게 슈카가 슈카도 좀 오르면 파는지 아니면 그냥 계속
안 팔고.
알려주세요.
들어갔다 나왔다 그러면 삼성전자 하이닉스 파는데 1년에 한 2번.
작년 같은 경우에는.
응.
1년에 한 번 사고.
여름에 한 번 사고.
돈이 없으니까 그다음에.
다 사갖고.
미술을 안 하니까.
네.
신용을 안 하니까.
쭉 들고 있다가 우리 스페인 간 때.
네.
3월 초에 박살 날 때 스페인에 있었거든 요.
응.
아 아침에 눈 뜯는데 마이너스 10%인 거야 10%.
어.
그래서 뭐 나는 이제 배우기를 그렇게 배웠으니까.
훈절.
훈절은 아니죠.
익절이죠.
쭉 올라온 건데.
어쨌건 추세가 꺾였으니까.
거기 던졌죠.
그때 던지고.
그리고.
다시 사고.
다시 샀죠.
다시 샀는데.
그리고.
아 진짜.
아 슈카도 깨졌어.
두 번 정도 사팔사팔하다가 아 이 장은 지금은 방향이 없다.
그래서 놀다가 최근에 또 한 3분의 1 정도.
3분의 1 정도 들어가는 상황인데.
삼성전자 하이닉스 현대차요.
네.
삼성전자 하이닉스 쪽으로.
삼성전자 하이닉스.
지금은 무조건 반도체 붙어 있어야죠.
뭐 어떻게 하겠어요.
저는 만약에 삼성전자 하이닉스가 갈 거라고 보면.
네.
그냥 반도체 레버리지 사면 되잖아요.
레버리지는 아니에요.
저는 심지어 하이닉스가 변동성이 세잖아요.
삼성전자로 도망쳐 있는 상황이에요.
왜요.
변동성이 커서.
이게 지금 변동성이 너무 크니까.
너무 크다.
왜냐하면 작년에는 하이닉스 100%로 갔어요.
왜냐하면 작년에는 추세가 상승장이었잖아.
맞아.
그러니까 당연히 내가 가르칠 수 있는 모든 변동성이 제일 높은 종목에 100%를 갔는데.
지금은 이제 횡보장이거나 얼마 전까지 하락장일 수도 있고.
횡보장이니까 변동성이 좀 낮은 거에 들어가 있죠.
감사합니다.
물론 그래갖고 요즘에 하이닉스가 좋으니까 상대적인 실적이 안 좋기는 하지만.
네.
어쨌건 리스크가 있다고 생각하고 변동성을 좀 낮춰.
작년에는 하이닉스.
하이닉스를 많이 했죠.
그런데 고민이.
저는 사실 하이닉스 최근에 너무 사고 싶은데.
삼성전자는 20만 원이니까 살 만해.
하이닉스 100만 원 너무 비싸.
절대 가격이 비싼 건 의미가 없어요.
저는 이해가 돼요.
그래요?
뭘 이해가 돼요.
이해가 되기는.
우리 학부의 명예를 훼손시키지 마세요.
그런데 슈카님도 어쨌든 둘 다 잘 갈 거라고 보시잖아요.
둘 중에 하나만.
하나만 골라줘.
삼성전자 하이닉스 중에.
하이닉스 근데 좀 비싸긴 해.
저는 상승장이면 하이닉스.
하이닉스.
횡보장이면 삼성전자에 있을 것 같은데.
저는 사실 올라가고는 있지만.
시장 전체 펀더메탈에 대한 확실히.
작년마다 훨씬 부족하니까 리스크 관리하고 있죠.
코코 레버리지.
코코 150 레버리지.
어떻게.
알겠습니다.
오늘 개미는 지금 세 분과 함께 해봤는데.
와 진짜 역대급이에요.
계속 지금 고정으로 모셔달라고.
저는 사실 너무 모시고 싶은데.
자꾸 안 좋은 모습도 보여주셔야 되니까.
괜찮으시려나.
괜찮아요.
왜냐하면 본업을 워낙 잘하시니까 사실.
어차피 그렇게 잘하시진 못했잖아요.
30년간.
왜.
제가 봐온 모습으로는.
지금 피계법인 대표님이시고.
이혼 전문 변호사님이시고.
그리고 자꾸 형이 어디 가서 소개시켜달라는데.
그 이혼 전문이니까.
그러니까.
소개시켜주기가 좀 그래.
방송에 나오고 나서 혹시 문의가 조금 이혼 전문이니까.
아니 전혀.
전혀.
여기 아저씨 알고리즘 잘 안 뜨니까.
아저씨 알고리즘이 아니요.
이거는 조금 젊은 사람들이 많이 보다 보니까.
아마 이제 이분들이 자라서.
나중에 예비 고객님이.
고객이 되면 안 되는데.
안 되는데.
뭐 살다 보면 이제 리스크가 있을 수 있는 거죠.
아 이혼하면 찾아간다는 분들 좀 계시네요.
알겠습니다.
우리 또 회계사님.
괜찮으시겠죠.
제가 이제 슈카에 대한 마음의 짐으로 나와달라고 해서 나왔는데.
그때는.
마음의 짐이 있었어요.
예전에 게임방에서 게임하다 도망가고 그래서.
아 게임방 시점.
게임할 때 밥도 많이 사주고 그랬어요.
아 진짜로.
맞아요.
슈카님이 왜 밥 사줬어요.
돈이 많았어요.
용돈을 많이 받았어요.
아 진짜 돈이.
아 엄마 돈으로.
세상 인싸였네.
저는 처음 불렀을 때 변호사 회계사 이렇게 부른다고 그래서.
뭐 전문적인 거 물어볼 줄 알았어.
아니 그러려면.
아 낚였구나.
그러려면 형을 안 불렀지.
갑자기 며칠 안 남았는데 니디님이 문자가 와가지고 계좌 깔아는 거예요.
이게 뭐야 이게.
그래도 두 분의 희생 덕분에 우리가 이렇게 한 시간 반 동안 웃었어요.
근데 이분들도 어디 가면 엄청 있어 보이는.
그러니까.
있어 보이는 게 아니라 실제로 사짜 저 직업이시잖아요.
우리 옛날에 주식은 지금 할 때 천준범 변호사가 나와서 막 설명해 줬잖아요.
그러니까.
여기 앉으면 똑같이 안녕하세요.
천 변호사예요.
이렇게 된다니까.
계좌 까면 동등해.
저희가 더 나을 수도 있어요.
저희가 최고치일 수도 있어요.
계좌를 한번 저도 궁금하네요.
보면 안 돼.
굉장히 좀 험할 수 있다.
험할 수 있어요.
아무튼 두 분이 너무 희생을 해 주셔서 너무 감사드리고.
또 한 두 달 뒤에 또 한번 모셔서.
또 근황을 업데이트 한번 그냥 뭐 마실 나오시듯이.
진짜 다음번에 혹시 초대하시면은.
네 네.
진짜 우량주로.
우량주는 필요 없어요.
동전주도 괜찮은데 번 모습으로.
오케이.
한 달에서 한 두 달 한 달 반 정도 시간 드릴 테니까.
두 달.
딱 해갖고 이번에는 제대로 한번 번 모습으로 두 달 뒤에.
오늘의 개미는 지금 우리 슈카님 찐친 분들과 함께해 봤습니다.
니니씨의 개미는 지금 이 팟캐스트 요즘 갈수록 잘 나가는 것 같아요.
조회수가 너무 잘 나고 있어요.
지금 그래서 사실 이거 한 두 달 해보고 안 되면 접으려고 그랬거든요.
근데 잘 되고 있어가지고 접을 수가 없어.
광고가 계속 들어와.
광고도 받았어.
광고 오늘 두 개 받았어.
우리 자산은요.
아정당.
아 그래요.
얼마면 광고할 수 있나요.
회계법인.
회계법인 광고.
오.
환영.
대환영.
아니 물어보는 거예요.
아니 그러면은 저희가 출연료를 못 드리니까 광고라도 좀 무료 광고
로 좀 해드려야 되나.
출연료를 우리가 못 드린다고요.
응.
출연료 안 드릴 수 있어요.
출연료 안 드리고.
아 푼돈은 안 받아요.
원래 출연료 주는 거였어요.
출연료.
아 우리가 내야 돼요.
아니야.
내는 거 아니지.
모르셨으면 안 드려야 돼요.
아니야.
없던지 없던지.
아무튼 또 광고가 필요하시면 저희 개미는 지금 언제든 열려 있습니다.
이 두 달 뒤에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.
출연료 내셔도 돼요.